this is a joke but it's not is it we're
going to show the flag around this
contentious area are there Chinese
warships there or is that a potential
threat there are absolutely Chinese
warships Chinese military aircraft China
basically claims the entire South China
Sea they caught the nine dashed line
which runs all the way around this
impinges on the waters of the
Philippines of Vietnam and the other
nations around there so the Chinese are
building artificial islands they built
3,000 acres of artificial islands out
there to try and bolster their claim
we're going to go within 12 miles of
those things we're going to fly over
them because they're not real Islands
they're part of international airspace
and the international ocean how will
they respond to one of our boats going
off how many nuts do we go underway 12
miles up wid ghosting we'd go slowly
around 15 16 what kind of cruise by show
the flag it's not anything military
we're not launching missiles or bombs or
planes or anything else but these are
international waters and we need to
demonstrate freedom of navigation how
fast could this escalate do you see any
potential for it escalating I think it's
highly unlikely that china is going to
come out and get in a direct
confrontation they'll probably come out
and conduct close surveillance they'll
probably over fly our ships we will warn
them on the radio I doubt we're going to
see missiles flying between the two
nations but it is of a piece with the
growing pressure between the United
States comics and an exercise in keeping
military morale high I wouldn't say
military morale so much funny as it is
emphasizing that we have to be free to
operate on the high seas and in
international airspace more value I
think the next time you're here we will
speak of the Philippines Admirals to
Venus is at the Fletcher School of Tufts
University